we just want black people in space
fighting dragons can't we
well just a nerd who happens to be black
there are black nerds in the community
and we're not always represented yeah
like I love comics and everything anime
being a blurred is like not being afraid
of being the same thing as everybody
else I mean is black my die-hard love of
comic book TV shows and movies I dressed
up as all sort of characters I've
dressed as traditionally white
characters male characters when I was
like a kid like everyone in the
neighborhood they called me earth boy
because I was super into science and
collected bugs the black bird oh my god
what about it part of cosplay is posting
your pictures online there's always
gonna be trolls people just being
naysayers be the black character or I am
the black version I am just happen to be
black the characters don't exist I can
make it however I want to I'm just being
the fan you know shouldn't matter
so these guys a trailer for a new TV
show coming out digging the soup does he
have those powers or is it the suit
that's what I'm trying to figure out -
I'm not gonna lie I'm a sucker for like
an superhero action I'm gonna look like
bad in my sight I love it yeah in a city
yeah it was great actually I like you
because again I'm a familiar with all
the other shows but this comes close to
home and they're like making it very
like urban with a street gang and
Stephanie understands that there's
violence in the streets no one's doing
anything about it so now he has to
separate another black superheroes oh
[Laughter]
the car cars okay we're gonna get
superheroes yeah I'm gonna need your
help cuz you do this is your thing the
sword bullets never touch you you get
the lobster claw chicken I'm taking this
chicken guys you have so many weapons
I'm worried about you
[Music]
who knows crushing
[Music]